i take some things from the super the uh
the game day morning
um uh text exchange mooch sent out this
photograph of him and kurt
for the i guess 2017
game changers episode the nfl network uh
a show called game changers where mooch
would have three prospects coming into
the
um coming into the nfl draft and work
them out
and talk about the life and talk about
the game and there's curt
because these are the three quarterbacks
that were going into the draft
um you've got uh brad kaia of miami
davis webb of cal and texas tex
patrick mahomes uh unfortunately i
believe only
one of these youngsters from the game
changers
are uh uh to change the game
davis webb and mariucci accused in the
text exchange kurt warner of trying to
change patrick mahomes throwing motion
and that's how i bring
my my friend
who's calling the game on westwood one
radio uh
kurt warner how are you kurt i am good
rich
i am good it's uh so he's great to hear
how you're going to lead into this
i don't know doesn't sound like there's
any appreciation in your voice right now
kurt got to be honest
don't think i'm i'm centered for the
appreciation
well you know you never tell the whole
story and mooch never tells the whole
story
and i'm just here to kind of just take
my shots and i'll just
no no move on no it's okay but uh so
let's let's start with this one
uh when you did see mahomes that day uh
and you did
spend some time around him before andy
reid traded up to go get him in the
draft
what was what was your what was your
thoughts on on on mahomes uh clearly i i
don't think anybody saw
his first three years as a starter first
four years in this league coming
but yeah what did you what did you see
out of him that day
kurt well i think uh you definitely saw
the skill set you definitely saw the
talent level
in his arm um you know still to this day
i mean that the one thing that kind of
would jump out at you
especially for a guy like me that's all
about technique because that's how i had
to play the game
um he was very unorthodox in in how he
threw the ball
and you know some of the balance or the
arm angles and some of those different
things that
i think always concern you about a
quarterback because
you know a lot of guys when they have
those kind of deficiencies or their
technique is a little bit off
it translates into not being very
consistent or successful on a football
field
um but obviously we know that there's
some guys that are different like you
know aaron rodgers i would never take a
young guy and say hey
try to learn how to throw like aaron
rodgers because he does it differently i
mean there's times he's got
both feet off the ground and he's making
a 35-yard throw
patrick mahomes is very much in that
mode and that was the thing that you
couldn't see
at game changers when we're you know
thrown into spots or we're trying to do
drills
you couldn't see everything else that
comes into play
when you're talking about patrick
mahomes so saw the talent level
uh you saw the unorthodox nature of how
he threw and that was
my biggest concern and then to your
point your mutual now he wanted to
change his throwing motion a little bit
i would still i would still like to take
him and tighten some things up because
i think if he did that he would be even
better he would be even more consistent
but
the bottom line is he's just one of
those rare beasts that understand how to
throw the ball from different platforms
has a unique ability to connect his mind
to his body um and he overcomes so much
of the stuff that
most guys wouldn't normally be able to
overcome
and have you spoken to him yet for game
day morning i know you've already spoken
to brady correct
is that uh yes i've actually i i have
spoken to both of you okay so what did
you do
early okay so what did you walk me
through what you what you found with
both of these guys who
i mean look we're we're we
it's such a huge matchup we know that
and i think the matchup is only going to
get larger
uh in our you know dashboard
not our rear view mirror or i guess in
our rearview mirror once we we keep on
uh moving forward with mahomes career
and whenever brady finally does decide
to
hang them up what what did you find out
from both of these guys this week
in your conversation i mean you know
you just kind of find out you know even
when you do these interviews you
you you try to go different angles but i
think the bottom line what usually comes
out in an interview is
who these guys really are and that's
what came out to me in both of these
interviews is that patrick
um he is a great kid is a humble kid
uh but is still a kid and you know and
approaches the game
like that uh you know one of the fun
things that hopefully makes the the
interview for for game day morning is
and i was asking about some of those
crazy plays that they come up with and i
was asking them you know
is it andy reid that that comes up with
these plays
or has it gotten to the point now where
you or some of the other guys come in
every week
and and bring some of those fun things
to him he goes
cat now it's like me and kelsey and ty
we were over on the side of practice
and we're practicing these different
moves and trying to sell them so we can
go over to big red and say hey
coach we practice this we think this
will be really good and so
it's fun to see that approach because
when you watch the cheese play
it very much seems like that doesn't it
seems like they're all having a blast
and they're having fun and they're doing
back flips and
travis kelsey is being travis kelsey and
and patrick mahomes is playing out in
the backyard and that
very much comes across on you know in
the interview
and when you sit down and talk to him
and get to know him and then on the
other side
uh you get tom brady who is the ultimate
competitor
and everything is about getting every
advantage
and taking advantage of every moment and
trying to get to as many super bowls as
he can and trying to
beat everybody that gets in his path and
that is his
mindset in everything that he does and
he's there's no signs of stopping it
um you know i even asked him at one
point like do you ever consider that
this may be your last super bowl and he
actually said yes i was
i was you know thinking that he might
just say nope i i'm planning on playing
longer and i'm planning on being more
super bowls and that's just
what i do but he's very business-like
and he's very professional and um yeah
everything he does i think is meticulous
and uh he's got a reason for everything
and that comes across in the interview
as well is that sometimes i want him to
kind of break his shell and
have a little bit more fun but um but
this is who he is and this is how he's
wired and it's why
we're watching a guy do something that
no one's ever done and that maybe no one
will
ever do in this game is because that is
how he approaches this game in this
profession
uh and he's the ultimate competitor and
we're trying we're grasping all of us in
the media
um and just a fandom or just grasping it
to try and
you know there's no answer to the
rhetorical question can you believe
brady's still doing this
um but the the perfect person to try and
get an answer out of would be the person
who he beat
in his first super bowl and what do you
think
when you're sitting down interviewing
brady for his 10th super bowl and you
were in the first
competing with him kurt i mean what goes
through your head
when that happened yeah i i mean it's
just it's almost hard to fathom
rich yes so you know i i i remember when
i was growing up and i i said to myself
okay
i wanna be a quarterback that starts in
five super bowls because
when i was growing up you know nobody
had ever started in five and then john
elway ended up starting in five but
that was kind of my goal and now i think
to myself and you got tom brady
and kids can't even dream to play in 11
super bowls i mean
you can't even dream for that and so
most kids are looking to go well okay
tom brady will be number one and then
i'll shoot for number two and maybe i
can get
to six it is just incredible to think
what he has stacked
uh on top of you know everything else
year
in a year out what he's done this year
and i think it's what makes this game so
compelling is that you have tom brady
and the guy that you know two years ago
rich we were all talking like
this will never be done before there's
no chance that anybody
ever does what tom brady does now here
he is playing against the kid that's 25
that will be playing in his second super
bowl and now we're starting to go oh my
gosh
this is a battle of you know a lot of
people say maybe the two best
quarterbacks
will ever see when it's all said and
done but more importantly it's the goat
hands down the goat in tom brady but
it's the one guy that we see that we say
maybe maybe maybe this guy can do it i
don't know if anybody else will ever be
able to do it i don't know if any kid
will ever be able to dream about it
but here's the one guy that is set up at
this stage in his career where we say
ah there's a possibility and that to me
is what makes this so unique and so
special we got the goat
and the next greatest and uh he's got
the one chance that we think to
maybe rival the guy that he's playing
against
and as you said goes all the way back to
when i played and that's when the legend
started
it's still going on and it's kind of
like the best
you know coming to an end and we're
ushering in the next two decades of our
game
with the next great one and so it's just
it's phenomenal
and both of them you admire them and
respect them for who they are and how
they play the game and how they approach
this
and so i can't wait like everyone else
to to see these two guys go head-to-head
and these
two teams go head-to-head on the biggest
day well based on what you just said
kurt warner that's why i asked our
colleague who's going to be part of our
sunday super sunday extravaganza on nfl
network our pregame show that starts at
9am from raymond james i asked willie
mcginnis is it possible that brady at
any point in time
is in fact thinking about the fact that
mahomes is off such to such a great
start and if there is anybody you can
just maybe to use it with the phrase you
just said
just maybe get him that it's it's
mahomes and that's another reason why
brady as if he needs another log on that
uh all-time great fire that burns within
uh
it it gives him even an extra sense of i
gotta beat this kid because he's good he
might actually catch me one day and so
on behalf of my
65 year old self i need to do this like
literally
like does he think that and i'm
wondering if you think he does think
that
way potentially yes i quite frankly
think that
and again it's it's to me it's how tom
brady
is wired as much as anything is that a
he wants
to beat everybody in in every time he
plays
and yeah do i think there's a part of
him that says okay maybe this kid gets
to 10 super bowls
but i'll get to say yeah he went to 10
but i beat him in one
do i think tom brady thinks like that
without a question
i think tom brady things like that is
that he
understands all of that he sees the big
picture
and he wants to be the greatest and
all the great ones that's what goes
through their mind i want to be the
greatest
and to do that i've got to beat the
greatest or the next greatest or the
next great thing
and yes tom brady is wired like that and
i believe that goes through his mind
even though
there's a bigger picture and who he
plays against and the chiefs defense and
all that stuff
yes i believe uh that is in the mind of
tom brady as
everything else is as he takes all of
this in and and tries to you know take
down anybody in his past so the few
minutes i have left with you
my friend kurt warner um x know it for
me uh i i
i know that there's so many different
ways to go because of the number of
playmakers
that are at the disposal of these two
great quarterbacks and
defenses that have playmakers of their
own right the
buccaneers linebackers versus kelsey for
instance or the
the chiefs the way that they have been
able to uh put the bang thing on with
people with tyron matthew
uh ready to snipe somebody so how do you
have this all worked out
for super bowl 55 best you can lay it
out in a couple minutes um
yeah i mean yeah there's so many great
story lines that i that i could break
down
rich as you know but um the way you know
just big picture-wise i think the chiefs
are the better team
i think they are the better team across
the board i think they have more
ways to beat you i think they're more
explosive offensively
and i think they win this football game
um that does not mean that the bucks
don't have the pieces or aren't good
enough to win this game
there are multiple ways that they can
win this game and it starts with the
pass rush
against those two backup tackles can
they force patrick mahomes to be someone
different than
he usually is but i just believe that
the chiefs are the better team
have been more consistent are good in
these big moments
um and they find a way to to win this
game and
i also believe that this game has a
tendency
in my mind to not even be that close
that um that the chiefs could win this
game by by double digits based on
you know just the way that i see it play
out in my mind
outside of some of those those strange
things that could surely happen in this
big game
and then the strange thing potentially
well it's not strange i mean it's
weather
but if it rains uh we were talking about
this yesterday what
what what if there's a wet football does
it i said it because i listen to you
when you talk kurt
uh that the wet football is one it's one
thing but it's the wind that really is
something that that would affect
anything but what if it's a wet day
a rainy day in this game yeah i will say
depending on
the rain and how hard it rains because
that's one thing that you cannot control
right that if a ball is wet
and it slips out of your hand it flips
out of your hand and sometimes that can
be the nature to of super bowls because
as you know they they try to bring in
new footballs in the super bowl like
every play in the first half
so they can give them away or do
whatever they do and so often times
the balls aren't broken in really really
well
all the way through uh until they get
whatever that cycle is of balls in so
a wet ball a slick ball uh could that
have a hand in a game
without question and you know you have
to think if that were the case
it would probably lean in the direction
of the bucks you know putting into the
bucks favor
because they they run the football
normally better
uh tom brady has dealt with a lot of
weather and kind of the nature of how
they play as opposed to throwing the
ball down
the field but gosh you know this is why
i want all playoff games inside i do not
want to see
mahomes against brady in the rain not
being able to play their best
so i really really hope that uh that
it's a beautiful night and and we get a
chance to see our biggest stars
play their best football on the biggest
stage last one for you kurt i promise i
know you gotta run
um but uh you know the the last
quarterback that brady got also a ram
in golf are you surprised kurt about
what happened with goff
mcvay rams less need rolling uh
just going for it pulling out all the
stops getting stafford here
were you surprised by that yeah i was
surprised by it
um a young quarterback that has done
nothing but win
that has you know led you to a super
bowl
uh in his young career um yeah i i
really surprised that uh that he's not
there
and won't be the guy there for the long
haul
um but i also see the other side of it
is that
you know matthew stafford is a unique
talent he's a guy that
gives almost every team in the league an
upgrade from a physical standpoint
and a guy that can only can do what only
a few guys like the the rogers and the
mahomes and those guys
can do so i understand the intrigue
there
of that and i think on paper you might
say to yourself
well this this makes us a little bit
better
um you know from a big picture
standpoint but
um you know but i'm fascinated i'm
fascinated by it all because you know
we're in a league that what have you
done for me lately and
we're always looking for the next big
thing and i just
you know i feel bad to agree for jared
goff because he's done nothing but the
right
things and nothing but win uh and now
he's moving on to another place and i
wish him well and
and i'm excited to see what this rams
offense can be with stafford and that
division
um you know it's a great division
already and uh you know it's gonna be
fun to watch well i i know i said you
have to go i think i heard your skype
um is that your qb confidential call for
your new website
that you got right i'm actually gonna go
interview russell wilson in just a
second oh my gosh
uh all right well yeah uh but i
appreciate you know qb confidential i'm
gonna be launching here in the next
couple months uh i know you've seen some
of the videos that are out there on
social media but
it's just a teaching and instruction
platform that i've built kind of through
the pandemic to really
reach the masses with my passion for
this game whether you're a fan or a
coach or a player
that want to grow in your knowledge and
understanding or take your game to
another level
i'm gonna have stuff from blackboard to
on the field to in the playbook to in
the film room
um and then some some motivational stuff
based on my story to kind of
get your mind right and the mindset that
it takes to be great and so
i'm pumped about it um you know to
follow me on tv confidential on twitter
instagram facebook
obviously kurt 13 warner is my twitter
handle where a lot of the stuff kind of
goes out and i'll be giving people
updates and letting them know what we're
doing and uh
hopefully uh it'll be a great platform
to to impact our game for the next
generation kurt i will see you on our i
guess game day morning
uh zoom later on for our uh our
our our pre-show meeting later on today
and i'll see you in tampa i love you man
we'll chat soon all right love you too
buddy can't wait right back at you
there's kurt warner
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here